in our ion money a recent survey shows
what Americans think about being ready
for retirement 60 percent of workers are
very or somewhat confident about having
enough money to live comfortably during
retirement but only 41 percent admit to
crunching the numbers to see how much
they will need CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger is here Jill good
morning are we overconfident here we may
be because the funny thing about that
survey is that 60% say hey I'm confident
but only 40% have actually crunched the
numbers sorry that's a little bit
strange and I think that the crunching
the numbers part is so important it
starts with understanding how much
you're spending today which people
cannot stand doing but there's lots of
apps for that so you figure out what
you're spending right now and then you
want to project out into the future and
you do that by saying okay what's the
stream of income maybe I'm lucky enough
to have a pension I'll get some Social
Security and what will I maybe make from
some of the savings that I've
accumulated you figure that out and I
know there are a lot of calculators
online the place that did this survey
the eBRI has a nice tool it's called the
choose to save ballpark estimate very
easy to use that's what is retirement
well you know I also cool question you
are not actually interested in it so
that's good yeah I would say this when
most people I'm a certified financial
planner by training when people used to
come into my office what would they say
they say I want to retire what they what
do they really mean they mean I want to
feel comfortable enough to live the life
I lead today in the future without
working this hard and that really might
mean that you've got to do some extra
savings so we know that retirement
confidence it's very much linked to
whether or not you have a retirement
account so those who have the 401 K or a
403 B that's terrific but if you don't
have that kind of account it's a little
bit more problematic we tell people to
open an IRA or Roth IRA 5,500 bucks you
can put away 6500 if you're over 50 but
I have to tell you there's a plans for
the government for people who are saving
very very small dollars it's called the
my RA
my RA dot-gov what kind of looks like
Myra it's funny-looking but that allows
you to put as little as a couple of
bucks in every
month a way for the future really
important to look at and if you leave
your job what do you do with your
savings like in your 401k well there's a
pitfall about this so there's a few
options you can leave your money there
if the plan allows it you can roll it
over into an IRA IRA rollover account or
you can move it into your new job but
here's the thing too many people are
literally just taking the money out
there taking a distribution it's taxable
if you're under the age of 59 and a half
there are there are penalties involved
this is called leakage and a study from
Boston College found that taking that
money out early can actually reduce your
retirement income by as much as 25% so
we don't want people to do leave it in
the box
yeah absolutely among current retirees
nearly 8 out of 10 say they are very or
somewhat confident about having enough
money to live comfortably that's up 4%
from a year ago so what explains that is
that hubris or is that legit
I think it's legit I think that people
were feeling more in the survey they
said they were more confident about
being able to cover health care costs so
that's good but also look the stock
market's up pretty nicely so people feel
good more confident that's good savings
strategy stick with your plan don't dip
into early thank you Joe yeah always
great information Barrington time as we
do tax season
this morning's ion money sponsored by
Bright House Financial established by
MetLife